[Musik]
wir kommen an diesem ersten
weihnachtsfeiertag bei kurzen heute
nachrichten und die beginnen wir mit der
mahnung des bundespräsidenten dass man
30 jahre nach dem fall der mauer einheit
freiheit und demokratie nicht als
selbstverständlich nehmen dürfe wir
brauchen die demokratie sagte steinmeier
in seiner weihnachtsansprache aber vor
allem brauche derzeit die demokratie uns
wie er das meint
das für frank buchwald mehr miteinander
reden auch mehr streiten dazu hatte der
bundespräsident zu weihnachten
vergangenen jahres aufgerufen
heute stellte fest das sind sehr
politische zeiten in denen wir leben und
von zu wenig meinungsfreiheit kann in
meinen augen nicht die rede sein ganz im
gegenteil so viel streit war lange nicht
vor allem der streit ums klima habe die
politische debatte bestimmt weiteres
thema hass im netz der bundespräsident
ermutigt zum widerspruch auf jeden
einzelnen komme es an
sie entscheiden ob die krassesten und
lautesten parolen mit immer neuen klicks
belohnt werden oder ob sie auf fakten
vernunft und bessere argumente setzen
tief eingeprägt habe sich ihm vor allem
ein bild eine mächtige dicke tür aus
holz und eisen 20 schüsse hat sie
abbekommen die eingangstür der synagoge
von halle nach einem anschlag im oktober
diese angegriffene eingangstür zur
synagoge
sie steht in meinen augen für noch mehr
sie steht auch für uns
demokratie brauche keine helden sagt
steinmeier auch 30 jahre nach dem
mauerfall aber gelte es sie täglich zu
verteidigen
jetzt leben wir seit 30 jahren einheit
freiheit und demokratie nur nehmen wir
das bitte nicht als selbstverständlich
wir brauchen die demokratie aber ich
glaube derzeit braucht die demokratie
vor allem uns nachdenkliche worte des
bundespräsidenten oder ein auftrag an
alle nicht nur zur weihnachtszeit
komplett gibt es die weihnachtsansprache
gleich zu sehen direkt nach diesen
nachrichten wie die ansprache des
bundespräsidenten ist auch der segen des
papstes in rom weihnachtstraditionen den
er vom petersdom aus den gläubigen in
aller welt spendet in seiner ansprache
ging franziskus vor allem auf das
schicksal der migranten ein
die ihr leben auf der flucht riskierten
und der bart um schutz für sie annette
hilsenbeck bei strahlendem sonnenschein
sind zehntausende auf den petersplatz
gekommen um gemeinsam mit papst
franziskus weihnachten zu feiern und
urbi et orbi zu empfangen den segen für
die stadt und den erdkreis der besagt
dass alle sünden vergeben werden
[Musik]
in seiner weihnachtsbotschaft spricht
der papst besorgt über krisen und
konflikte in südamerika afrika und im
nahen osten mahnt die nationen sich um
frieden zu bemühen und bittet inständig
um schutz für migranten ist die
ungerechtigkeit die sie dazu zwingt
wüsten und mehrere die zu friedhöfen
werden zu überqueren
und es ist die ungerechtigkeit die sie
abweist von orten wo sie hoffnung auf
ein würdiges leben haben könnten und wo
sie auf eine mauer von gleichgültigkeit
stoßen die gläubigen nachdenklich und
bewegt von den worten des papstes
es ist absolut wichtig dass wir uns im
klaren sehen dass wir was machen müssen
für den weltfrieden und dass wir helfen
müssen uns gegenseitig wir sind alle
gleich das ist ein symbol ist eine der
wichtigsten aussagen
es gibt lange die liebe ist das
wichtigste das ist die botschaft am ende
der papst fast leutselig er wünscht
guten appetit
eine weihnachtsfeier deren intensive
botschaft bei den besuchern angekommen
ist
[Applaus]
die gesetzlichen krankenkassen werden
2009/10 wohl erstmals seit vier jahren
wieder verluste machen und zwar mehr als
eine milliarde euro
das sagte die verbandschefin der
krankenkassen doris pfeiffer der funke
mediengruppe im vergangenen jahr hatte
es noch ein plus von 2 milliarden
gegeben
grund seien auch neue gesetze wie das
zur stärkung des pflegepersonals ab 2021
könnte es deshalb zu höheren
zusatzbeiträgen kommen nach afrika dort
sind bei terrorangriffen in burkina faso
mehr als 100 menschen getötet worden
darunter dutzende zivilisten
laut behörden griffen dschihadistische
kämpfer die stadt erbin da an die norden
des landes liegt außerdem einen nahe
gelegenen militärstützpunkt die
hintergründe sind bislang unklar
in australien wüten weiter schwere
waldbrände und eine entspannung der lage
ist vorerst nicht in sicht besonders
betroffen ist der bundesstaat new south
wales im südosten des kontinents in dem
auch die metropole sydney liegt die
feuerwehrleute kämpfen in
sonderschichten gegen die flammen
sie erleben ein weihnachtsfest im
ausnahmezustand wie david sauer
berichtet
jingle bells am bondi beach in sydney
ein mal am strand weihnachten feiern vor
allem für touristen etwas ganz
besonderes aber festtagsstimmung kommt
kaum auf zu nahezu real ist die gefahr
durch die brände die sich ein paar
kilometer entfernt durch die hügel
fressen die feuer machen keine pause
also machen auch die feuerwehrleute
keine das alles hört wenn ich einfach
auch nur weil weihnachten ist also
müssen viele von uns auch heute ran und
die brände überwachen
immerhin auf der wache gibt es ein paar
aufmerksamkeiten von helfern
das ist doch das mindeste was man in
dieser situation tun kann
ich habe für die helden ein paar dutzend
cupcakes gemacht wind hitze extreme
dürre seit wochen geht das so eine
fläche größer als die schweiz ist schon
verbrannt
an heiligabend gab es nördlich von
sydney die ersten schauer seit monaten
aber meteorologen geben keine entwarnung
nein im gegenteil sagen sie für die
kommenden tage bis zu 45 grad und
trockenheit voraus sie fürchten nun dass
sich zwei brände vor der stadt zu einer
gewaltigen feuerwand vereinigen
schlechte nachrichten zu weihnachten
schnitt wer lotto gespielt hat der hofft
jetzt wohl auf ein besonderes
weihnachtsgeschenk hier sind freaks sein
die gewinnzahlen lauten 17 22 33 36 41
47 und die superzahl 2 weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auch für lotto
punkt zdf.de und im zdf text auf seite
55 7
und wir haben noch das wetter für den
zweiten weihnachtsfeiertag da überwiegen
die wolken im osten kann es vereinzelt
auch schauer geben
etwas sonne zeigt sich vor allem ganz im
norden und südlich der donau die
temperatur zwischen drei und acht grad
so viel von uns für den moment um
viertel nach elf gibt's nochmal
spätnachrichten und hier geht es jetzt
weiter mit der ansprache des
bundespräsidenten
ich verabschiede mich bis morgen und
wünsche im namen der gesamten heute
mannschaft frohe weihnachten